ただ 生き続くために必要な最低限に自分の体を認識しているだけなんです
我々は歩くときは足の感覚を知ってます
歩く瞑想しなくても 知ってますけど
それは無事歩けるぐらいで
いわゆる最低限にそこに集中しているだけ
それで歩きながら人と喋る
周りを見ると 妄想をするとか
いろんなことをやってるんですね
いわゆるわずかな力で足を認識しているんです
食べるときもまるっきり認識してないと食べられないんです
ちゃんと見て食べて味わって
見て食べて味わって それで十分だというふうに
その認識はすごい働いてます
念 サティは 働いてるんだから
ちゃんと適当に食べられるようになる
でも食べながら他のことも考える
喧嘩もする いろんなことをまたやる
それをなぜやってるかというと
この最低限 ただ生きるために必要な
それぐらいしか使ってない
他のエネルギーはもう余計にもう暴走させちゃう
念のエネルギーは そこで菩提樹になるということは
逆に随念するんですね
歩くときは足の動きに
感覚に徹底的に集中する
して感じてみる もう他のこと見る考える暇はもうまるっきりない
足は上がりますと運びますと下ろしますという
その感覚にもう全力を絞るんです
認識的に 認識の力を それで四念処の念になるんです
それは修行ですから そういう風にこの念の力はもう全部絞って一つに集中する
自分の場合も同じ 痛いとかね
みんないつでも知ってます
痛いや寒いやとかね 楽だと気持ちいいとかね
感覚は でも適当にほどほどに
最低の 最低限の力でそれを感じているだけ
それは瞑想にはなりません
ですから 痛みを感じるときは
もう他の何も見る暇が心ない
痛みとそれだけ集中して全力を絞ってそれをサティをするんです
そういうふうにやる時だけサティパッターナなんです
日常生活にあるサティはサティではありません
それはただ死なないために
無事に生きているために
どうせ必要な基本の時だけ
例えば人間で生まれたら手があるんだったら
手でいろんなものを書くということは誰にでもできます
生まれつきでもできます
生まれつきの子供にでも手にペンなんか握ってあげて
紙をあげたらもうこうやって手を動かすんだからね
もうそれぐらい何か物は書けるし
物と言ったら何か書けるし
書けるものを書いた本にはいろんなものはもう出てくるんだという実感があります
それは文字でも絵でも何でもないんですね
そこで手の働きに徹底的に集中することによって
我々は文字の勉強やら絵の勉強ということになるでしょうし
それでその修行によって
この人は綺麗な文字が書けると
綺麗な絵を描けるということになっちゃうんですね
だから 生まれつき持っている能力は別に修行でも何でもないんですね
喉から声を出すということは
生まれた時からは赤ちゃんにできるんですね
それを放っておけば ただキャーキャーと泣くだけで終わっちゃうんですね
人生は だからこの犬はいつでも吠えるだけでしょうに
赤ちゃんは泣くだけでしょうし
泣く泣き声にはちゃんと赤ちゃんはそれなりの自分の表情を表しているんです
犬はワンワンと鳴くだけで喋っているんです
あれで 赤ちゃんもちゃんと喋っているんです
感情を表してはいるんです
だから赤ちゃんと犬の間は何の差もないんです
生まれつき付いてる能力だけだから
だから我々は犬は吠えてはいるんだけど
何だろうかとわからない時もわかる時もあります
赤ちゃんも泣く時は何だろうかとわかる時もわからない時もあります
それで赤ちゃんに修行させちゃうでしょう
修行させたところで言葉というものが出てきて
それで経験が出てきて
人にわかりやすく喋られるようになる
それをさらにさらに修行しちゃうと
立派に喋る話しかまでなってしまっちゃうんですね
ですから 生まれつきついているものはもう役に立たないということはまず理解してほしい
で 念というサティも同じく生まれつきはあるものなんですけど
それはこの 強力に力強く集中しちゃう
で それを修行で大変に役に立つんだと
ですから 悟りのために最初に必要なのはこの四つの念なんですね
身受心法の念 四種類のサティなんですね
だから適当にその時その時のものにも徹底的に絞ってサティを入れる
そうするならば それは菩提分枝にはなります
そこで次にある四つは精進なんですね
精進の四つも 精進っていうのは誰でもするんですが
生まれつき 子供はやっぱり精進するんだからおっぱいを吸ってるんです
頑張らなきゃ吸えませんだからね
それなりに本来生まれつきこういう
何て言いますか 本能みたいなものがあって
努力はする で 筋肉なんかものすごく動かして動かして動かして刺激を与えてあげて成長するようにしているんです
だから赤ちゃんというのはかなり激しく動くでしょうね
子供になってもかなり激しく動く
あれは運動しているんですね
運動して筋肉に刺激を与える
心 神経から刺激をもらうたびに
これ祖先だから成長するんですね
でもあれでオリンピック金メダル取る選手にはなりませんね
それだったらわざと特別に修行しなくちゃいけない
同じ運動なんです 赤ちゃんやら子供たちやってる遊びの運動と同じことなんですけど
特別に訓練することでオリンピックにも参加できるようになってしまうんです
ですから これ精進の場合は
人間っていうのは精進はしていますけど
その人間の精進は菩提の分枝にはならない
悟りの部分にはならないんですね
悟りの部分になる精進というのは
ウッパンナン・パーパカーナン・パハーナエ・ワーヤムー
すでに生じた悪を遮断するための精進
だからヴィパッサナー瞑想中でも怒りやら悪い心が生まれたら
それはやっぱり遮断しなきゃいかんですね
怒りが生まれたら怒り怒りだと確認したっても
怒りに徹底的に集中していたところで怒りがどんどん起こってしまうならば
それはヴィパッサナー
菩提分枝にはならなく
ならなくなっちゃうんですね
やっぱり悪いものは確認して遮断するということも必要なんですね
それからアヌッパンナーナン・クサラナン・ダンマーナン・ウッダーダエ・ワーヤムー
未だ生じたことがない悪が生じないための精進
未だ生じたことがない善が生じ
生じるための精進 すでに生じた善が壮大するための精進という四つでないと覚りの分身にはならないんですね
それも普通の人間には精進はありますが
それはもう役に立たない
それは特別に悪をなくすために
善を行うためにという二つの方向へ持っていって精進しなくちゃいけない
それから尽力という こちらこの
尽力っていうのは漢文で出てくることで
これこちらこの成就の基礎というふうに書いている
その意味は正しいんですね
何か成就するために基礎的に必要な力だと
で この前も説明して ちょっと前も説明しましたからね
だから尽力といっても
この前出たのはこの主として出た四つ
同じ四つなんです 同じ四つ
この尽力という場合はやっぱり覚りに関係あるんですね
それは何かというと意欲
それから精進 それから心
それから智慧 チャンダ・ヴィリヤ・チッタ・ヴィマンサ
チャンダ・ヴィリヤ・チッタ・ヴィマンサという四つですね
欲っていうのはみんなにあるんだけど
それはダメと 覚りたいという欲でなければ
精進はあるんだけど そんななんだどんな何でも精進はダメであって
この説明した通りの精進でなければ
心は持ってますけど それはきちんと強化しなくちゃいけないし
それからわずかな智慧があるんだけど
それはそれでダメなんです
から 徹底的に集中して観察するということは育てなくちゃいけない
そこでインドリヤというのは根であって
いわゆる窓口みたいなもの
それは五つですね 信と精進と念と定と智慧
それは窓口として 自分の覚りのシステムの中で
その五つの窓口を通して働いてもらわないと
覚りは成功しない それだけじゃなくて力も必要なんですね
力も五つですね 同じもの
サッダ・ヴィリヤ・サティ・サマディ・パンニャーがまた力としても働かなくちゃいけない
そこで 覚りそのものが七つの因子でまた構成されると
ボディアンガ ボディのアンガ
これだけ覚支と書いてあるんですね
それ七つあるんですね
七覚支とね 有名な言葉ですからね
それは七覚支は何ですかというと
サティ・ダンマ・ヴィジャヤ・ヴィリヤ・ピーティ・パッサッディ・サマーディ・ウペッカー
これ説明したっけね この前
心配しなかったならばそこら辺で止めておくかないと
でもこのここで八正道まで終わればいくらかはまあ低レベルですけどね
どうしますかね 五分で説明できる時もあるし
一分でも説明できる場合もあるし
一時間 二時間説明できる場合もあります
どんなコースにしますか？じゃあそこら辺で終了しましょう